tha
[Musique]
oh
non
des prières et des offrandes pour
honorer les dieux c'est ainsi que les
croyants tamouls commencent leur
nouvelle année sur les pas d'hugh elles
brûlent encens juste à côté des fruits
et des parfums un plateau qui souligne
la dévotion et la préparation du croyant
[Musique]
et le carême corporelle donc on va lui
dire mais pas manger de viande avait
quand même sérieux et pas devient pas de
poisson pendant minimum trois jours et
après il ya le carême d'esprit ou avoir
une bonne conduite une bonne de bonnes
pensées de la terre avec les deux c2
privations ça nous permettre d'avoir de
récupérer une énergique et des divinités
comme c'est le dieu mais on veut qu'on
peut rien commencé sur va pas s'adresser
à cette divinité aux divinités donc tout
sauf qu'on entreprend ses comptes dans
notre vie à nous quand on se marie on
s'adresse à dieu en ce temps on est en
se baptisant le pouce harry récite des
prières en tamoul et ans inscrit ses
chants rituels raconte l'histoire des
divinités au travers de montres a sacré
pour cette cérémonie
chacune des statues a été purifiés
parfumé et revêtus de vêtements de
cérémonie
ben là c'est la pierre sacrée et en noir
la divinité direction de l'inde avec
l'énergie à l'intérieur et ce matin on a
on l'a déshabillé on a fait le bain
sacré avec tous les produits de lui le
miel le lait tous les ingrédients furent
on a fait le buzz comme comme une
personne en vie et après on a essuyé on
l'a préparé on l'a décoré avec les
décorations
on a mis des colliers de fleurs de
plastique des vêtements comme comme une
personne au temple maryen peroumal des
lobes les fidèles sont venus prier les
divinités
ici c'est le dieu vishnou le
préservateur le protecteur qui est adoré
c'est lui qui préserve laver et le
protecteur
donc nous moi bon c'est encore amassé
neuf il ya vingt ans à peu près mais ça
c'est par rapport à mon professeur qui
était un prêtre d'un temple vishnou
hisse donc pour continuer ce qui est
maman portrait mais je compte
on a décidé de consulter en vue chez
nous chaque tente à sa divinité
principal et tous les tampons des
divinités principal différente ici
david et pascal c'est le dur vichy par
exemple le grand 2 qui base à ses
homologues à celui de saint denis c'est
qu'à rallye donc chaque temps à sa
divinité principal mais on retrouve à
côté on retour à prouver presque tout
les mêmes dix minutes la communauté
indienne célèbre ce 14 avril la nouvelle
année 5119 une date basé sur le
calendrier lunaire qui fait référence au
jour ou brahma le créateur créé à
l'univers et notre monde une année
placée sous le signe de la sagesse et de
la réflexion tant donald va je trouve ke
villembits 5119 tout soit à tout le
monde une très bonne année et que les
ondes positives viennent proche de nous
pour pouvoir avancer tout doucement dans
la
du
[Musique]